Let's say that company
ABCD is some type
of a pharmaceutical company that
has a drug trial coming out.
And you're convinced--
it's right now trading
at $50 a share-- but you're
convinced that if the drug gets
approved, that the company's
stock is going to skyrocket.
And you're also convinced
that if the drug gets
rejected, that
the stock price is
going to tank to
maybe $5 or $10.
So if you wanted to make
money off of that belief,
and I'm not necessarily
recommending that you do.
It's always trickier in reality
than it sounds on paper.
But one way that you could
is you could actually
buy both the call option and
the put option on that stock.
The put option is going to make
you money if the stock tanks.
And then the call
option is going
to make money if the
drug gets approved
and the stock skyrockets.
So let's actually draw
the payoff diagram here.
So if the stock goes down,
let's say it goes down to 0,
you would exercise
the put option.
Because you could buy
the stock for zero,
exercise your put option,
and sell it for $50.
This is the right to
sell the stock for $50.
And of course, we're
talking about the value
of the combination
now at expiration.
So the stock is worth
zero at expiration,
the value of the put
option is worth $50.
The call option is
clearly worthless.
You wouldn't exercise
the call option
if the stock is worth zero.
You would want to buy something
for $50 that's worth 0.
So from the stock's being
worth zero, all the way up
to the stock being
worth $50, you
would want to exercise
the put option.
But the value of
the put option is
going to become lower
and lower and lower.
And anything above
$50, you wouldn't
exercise the put option at all.
But if you get
above $50, you would
want to exercise
your call option.
If the stock is worth
$60 at expiration,
then your call
option is worth $10.
Because you have the
right to buy something
for $50, which you
can sell for $60.
So then you have the value
of your call option going up.
So you can see a situation here.
When you just think
about the value
of this bundle of the
call plus the put option.
That it's not much value
if value of the stock
doesn't change from $50,
your options are worthless.
But if you have a
major movement, either
to the upside or the
downside, then this straddle,
it's called.
Let me write that down.
When you go long a call
and you go along a put,
this is call a long straddle.
In a long straddle you benefit
from a major price movement.
And when you think about
it from the profit and loss
point of view, you
just shift it down
based on the amount you
paid for the two options.
So in this case, we paid
$20 for both options.
So in this situation where
we would exercise the put,
instead of making
$50, we have to net
it for the $20 we
paid for the options.
So we would only make $30.
And at the point where we're
not exercising either option,
because they're both
essentially worthless,
no reason to exercise
them, then we essentially
have just lost $20
for both options.
So we will be down over here.
And then anything above $50,
will start to make money.
So let me draw the
option diagram over here.
It will look like
this, the payoff
diagram It will
look just like that.
So when you actually
factor in how much you
paid for the options,
you now see that you only
would make money
with this straddle
if the underlying
stock price, maybe
after the results of
the trial are released,
hopefully get released
before the maturity
of the actual options.
If the stock goes below $30,
or if the stock goes above $70.
But if it has one of those
major movements, then
this position, this
straddle, this long straddle
will make you money.